the FBI Hillary Clinton email saga may
be ended at this point we have yet
another letter from FBI director James
Comey saying it there will be no charges
against Hillary Clinton even now
considering these new emails on Anthony
Weiner's computer there was initially
this press conference some months ago
where James Comey announced there would
not be charges against Hillary Clinton
the trumpeters the right it's all rigged
it's all in the bag for Hillary Clinton
then last week we had an additional
letter from James Comey saying we found
more emails on Anthony Weiner's computer
we are going to be looking into these to
see if there's anything related to
Hillary Clinton or classified documents
that she may or may not have uh I've
been involved with her that were
connected to her email server all of a
sudden it's not rigged the FBI according
to the trumpeters is doing a hell of a
job absolutely tremendous job and then
yesterday after hearing from Fox News
late last week that an indictment was
likely we had another letter from FBI
director James Comey saying there will
be no charges and of course now the
election is back to being rigged
according to the trumpeters uh this was
another one of these letters that is
very confusing in terms of why we even
have this number of letters for an
investigation where there are no charges
came from FBI director James Comey i
will put part of it up on the screen for
you he said since my letter the FBI
investigative team has been working
around the clock to process and review a
large volume of emails from a device
obtained in connection with an unrelated
criminal investigation during that
process we reviewed all the
communications that were tore from
Hillary Clinton out while she was
Secretary of State based on our review
we have not changed our conclusions that
we expressed in July with respect to
Secretary Clinton I am very grateful to
the professionals at the FBI for their
extraordinary work what do you think Pat
I mean my view is there should never
have been a press conference to begin
with that would have made it so there
would never have been a second letter to
begin with and there would never have
been a third letter to begin with the
FBI should not comment on investigations
until there is actually something to
report well it's interesting because he
was forced to report to Congress any
time that something came up right look
like they they found 650,000 emails and
most of them were from a personal nature
I'm over number by the way right yeah
and were emails that had already been
looked at so it's it's really a sticky
situation for Comey you think that this
would end the whole investigation for
the time being but you know that the
Republicans are gonna put it through
hearings and maybe even an impeachment
trial yet it if that this may be the end
for James Comey both in terms of dealing
with this and also if Hillary Clinton is
elected this may be the end for James
commis tenure as director of the FBI
that's that kind of an issue we'll talk
about after tomorrow's election but the
other issue here is that no matter what
if Donald Trump does win tomorrow it's
not the end for the Republicans on this
issue they want more they love this
issue and it if he does win then you
have to point at this as the reason why
because he was so far down in the polls
before the story broke yeah and even
though the second letter has been
released I mean is not enough too little
too late to change things it's not like
the FBI now did nothing wrong because 48
hours before the election they come out
and they say all that stuff we did the
entire shifting of the momentum against
Hillary Clinton with last week's letter
during which early voting was going on
hey forget about out about all that
because now 48 hours before the election
when by some accounts thirty to forty
percent of the votes have already been
cast via absentee ballots and early
voting now we're good because we ended
up coming out and saying hey there
aren't going to be any charges here how
many people were influenced in their
votes based on James commis numerous
statements about this investigation and
then the people saying oh David you're
you're so naive David there's no way
they could review 650,000 email so
quickly number one they never said it
was six hundred and fifty thousand
emails and number two what do you know
if they can do this if they devote the
proper resources you filter out
duplicates using computers you remove
everything that doesn't include Hillary
Clinton as either sender or recipient
and then you put a team of people
looking at just those emails this is not
so difficult and as predicted according
to the trumpeters and Donald Trump the
election is now rigged again how
convenient and I want to talk about that
next